Martine St-Clair a repris cette
chanson qui est devenue très
populaire à l'été 1984.
♪ Il y a de l'amour dans l'air ♪
- Martine St-Clair, on va
revenir sur l'été 1984 avec
la chanson "Il y a de l'amour
dans l'air", c'est une reprise.
- Oui.
- Pourquoi vous avez décidé
de reprendre cette chanson-là?
Comment c'est fait le déclic?
- Bien, ce n'est pas
ma décision. À l'époque,
mon équipe - les disques Star -
me téléphonent une journée,
j'habite chez mon père et il me
dit : "J'ai une chanson
extraordinaire; elle a eu
une vie en France, ça s'appelle:
"Il y a de l'amour dans l'air".
♪ Il y a de l'amour dans l'air ♪
Ça parle un peu de cette jeune
fille qui... Qui voit l'amour
tout autour d'elle, mais elle,
elle l'attend. Alors je relis
les paroles, je lis les paroles
puis je fais comme : "Je ne peux
pas chanter ce texte-là,
c'est triste". Je dis...
je dis non à l'agent.
L'agent téléphone à mon père :
"Monsieur Nault, Monsieur Nault,
elle ne peut pas passer à côté,
ça va changer sa vie, c'est
une grande chanson, parlez-lui,
faites quelque chose". Alors
mon père me parle soir,
gros meeting au souper...
(rires)
... avec les sept autres à la
maison on est 8. Et donc il me
dit : "Martine, je pense que...
donne une chance à la chanson".
♪ Il y a de l'amour dans l'air ♪
♪ Et moi, je broie du noir ♪
- Est-ce que vous vous rappelez
de l'enregistrement de
"Il y a de l'amour dans l'air"?
Comment ça s'est passé?
Et surtout l'impact que ça a eu
cet été-là.
- Cet été-là, '84, comme vous le
mentionez, j'arrive... ce qui
est impressionnant, c'est que
j'arrive dans ce grand, grand
studio immense et puis je ne me
doutais pas qu'à la sortie
de ce studio, que ma vie allait
changer. Je retourne chez moi et
j'en ai des frissons.
Les téléphones commencent à
sonner.
Hein! Telle radio a accepté
la chanson. Hein! Tu fais comme:
"Bien voyons", on vient de
la faire. Alors que dans les
jours qui ont suivi, la chanson
était pressée et envoyée
dans les radios et puis
c'est devenu un succès,
je dirais presque momentané.
♪ Qu'on me donne ma chance ♪
- Pourriez-vous me chanter juste
le refrain et m'expliquer
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de magique
dans ce refrain-là?
- Ah! Oui ça allait comme :
♪ Il y a de l'amour dans l'air ♪
♪ Ce soir, il y a de l'amour
dans l'air ♪
♪ Et moi, je broie du noir ♪
♪ Il y a de l'amour dans l'air ♪
- Pour les gens, cette chanson,
on m'en parle encore
aujourd'hui, c'est comme
un hymne. Et il faut voir
le public quand j'attaque
ce premier refrain,
les yeux qui pétillent, les gens
qui sont heureux, il y a déjà
des applaudissements.
Je fais comme : "Bien voyons",
encore aujourd'hui et je dois
la chanter à chaque spectacle,
40 ans après et aujourd'hui pour
moi... Je sais très bien qu'il y
a de l'amour dans l'air,
c'est à l'intérieur de toi
tu sais qu'il y a de l'amour.
♪ Il y a de l'amour dans l'air ♪
♪ Il y a de l'amour ce soir ♪
(applaudissements)